how's it going bros my name is peter pat
and let's find out why my channel is
dying
[Music]
google trends everyone a wonderful tool
that seems
underutilized have you ever looked on
google trends
has anyone ever done this video before
am i the first one
oh my god did i just have an original
idea that's awesome few days ago me and
jack did a video where we
looked a little bit into google trends
but i want to really dig
deeper i want to truly understand why
everyone else is doing so god damn good
and now wait so let's find out
cool maybe my channel is dying because i
can't ride it
pewdiepie oh my god
well it looks like i'm not the only one
with this problem i dip you
who the hell is pie die poo norwegian
youtuber pie thai poo he's my favorite
he's so
funny he's so good all right let's just
go into this so here we get an interest
over time graph pretty interesting i
would say you know it's
it's there you don't really get the full
picture unless you hit
the whole graph so let's start up here
in 2012
this is when i i guess i started
becoming more popular
i'm not exactly sure what date represent
what
but i hit my peak at 2014.
what happened in 2014 i need to
understand
so someone made a playlist i guess i
played games in 2014.
no controversy no nothing
huh i'm actually in the same room
nothing's changed five years jesus
christ
when did i become the biggest channel in
2013.
damn it's been a long time it's 2013 and
then i
i peaked in 2014. and then it all just
it all just went down
i think it's interesting to note at
least for me because
anyone that came before me almost every
single channel that has
been before me has just disappeared okay
everyone that's been bigger than me
they've all they're all gone
because of this fact i've always just
looked at youtube like it could end at
any day like i should just be ready to
pack my
bags at any day i actually oh wait let
me see if i can find that sorry i'm this
video is just gonna be one giant tangent
so i did a i think in 2012 i did a
i did a presentation do not google it
for the love of god but i
i found the pictures
and i talked about you know doing let's
plays as a job
people didn't really know anything about
it at the time
look here i'm showing off my stats being
like hey guys
it's going pretty well there was one
information that i i was really
interested by
sick of boring let's plays i am your
salvator
i found the presentation where is it
beautiful
faces of horror okay so how did i get to
where i
am full time job two videos every day do
something different let myself into the
game a lot so what happens in the future
i thought it was interesting how i kind
of questioned how it was
something stable or not with laws and
regulations and copyright i thought
these things would hit
uh quicker i really i was so unsure
whether he would even be allowed to
monetize gameplay on youtube
i think it's it's one of those things
where people really fought for
and to try and convince companies as
well that it's benefit
fitting for them like these big cup
publishers like ea
bethesda whatever they benefit from
people playing their game and they
them understanding that has really had a
huge impact on uh
on youtube and gaming i can easily see
it going another way
where gaming would just not be allowed
on youtube and
that's always been in the back of my
head you know and now
in the future 2019 nothing's really
changed it's article 13 all this stuff's
happening i think this
is where wall street journal happened i
think it happened in february
because it was literally on valentine's
day it was here so this is a wall street
journal
and then just been kind of stable
for a long time and then jesus christ
t-series
but my favorite part of this graph is
when i go hey guys
let's end this subscribe pewdiepie meme
like we shouldn't do this anymore
okay skydive graph
you know this is the kind of reports you
want to see a full-on economic crash
thank you guys so much i can't wait to
hit 100 million subscribers
in a couple of years no one cares felix
fine
you know what this is just america what
if like in afghanistan i'm actually
popular
zero what about chad what about
chad god damn it chad
so according to this state of america
i am most popular in the state of lova
what the frick is that what the dumb
name of a state
lova what do you love so much
which country am i most popular in
thank you sweden very cool too bad
you're such a tiny
insignificant country come on
i need imagine if i was the biggest one
in india
oh my god this is so sad i am so
oppressed
if i was born in any other country
everything would be different
norway come on what is this
despite years of abuse norway's
norwegian bros are still here
thank you guys very good new zealand
australia
estonia what what is this
philippines is my second biggest country
damn filipino broth
thank you okay so what are the most
search related terms for pewdiepie
pewdiepie
swedish youtuber i don't understand why
people
make it all about me being swedish i
never make my channel about being
swedish
of course t-series number two so this is
what most people have searched and
related to me
i think that's what it is and then the
third most related is my net worth sorry
marx yeah you're not as important
but i said comes forth my net worth
pewdiepie net worth
so basically what this means is that
most people that search pewdiepie
search pewdiepie net worth so really in
reality what i should do is i should
title this video pewdiepie net worth
and i will inevitably give me a lot of
views based on search terms
according to this i um my net worth is
20 million
20 million dollars
it's more i am sorry but it's a bit more
than that
google i don't know exactly how net
worth is
measured but if it's based on how much
money on my bank account
then i'm sorry you're coming a little
short there buddy
oh god damn it it turns out i've already
done the net
i've already done the net worth meme
marzia pizzugnin
italian internet personality let's look
at how marseille is doing
oh projection that he might go up
well that's good connecticut okay
happy wheels video game guys happy
wheels
video game i can't believe that's the
fifth highest
people always associated me with horror
games but i guess
happy wills is bigger markiplier
that's insane so many people google me
and markiplier
we barely done any videos together we
did this one
as no one says there it is scare
pewdiepie
scare pewdiepie at 100 million let's get
it please
all right so let's compare to another
youtuber what's a youtuber doing well mr
beast
never mind what wait
oh okay he's doing really well okay
nevermind
jesus christ australia and new zealand
do you do anything but watch youtubers
mr beast network networks me miss peace
pewdiepie
how are they how are the paul brothers
doing look at this dude
holy sh look how much bigger they were
than me at some point
that's crazy so jake paul has
technically been bigger than i've ever
been
not me all right who's bigger than logan
and jake paul
holy sh dude holy [ __ ]
okay so logan is blue i'm red look at
logan
holy [ __ ] that's nuts so
the the suicide forest was literally
uh four times as big
as the pewdiepie versus t-series stuff
that's nuts that is
crazy am i the only one interested by
this
okay so we now know
we are failing but that doesn't mean we
give up god damn it
subscribe god damn it i need 100 million
there's another website that
lets you look at statistics and
analytics
of course socialblade i used to be
obsessed with socialblade and i think a
lot of youtubers are
a lot of youtubers go on socialblade and
they look at their own stats
and they compare it to other people and
they they frantically
i think that makes a lot of people
really really depressed
why am i laughing dude what's wrong with
me it's just that
imagine that you have a job and how well
you are performing
in that job is 100 public
and 100 comparable to all your peers
like there's some deep psychological
emotional stress
that is always lingering for a lot of
youtubers i literally
have not gone on social blade in like
four years i i just stopped i don't know
why what happened
after a while it just luckily it just
ironically it hit me
it doesn't matter like i don't care how
many subscribers i have i
it doesn't matter and i don't have to
waste time just obsessing about this
stuff but i do remember
i used to obsess about this stuff and i
think a lot of youtubers do especially
comparing themselves
so my views are up yay my subscribers
are
subscribed please
[Music]
estimated monthly earnings yeah seems
about right
i used to complain so much when i saw
these estimated monthly earnings but
like
that's ridiculous how could i possibly
make that much money
and then clearly i have been very poorly
monetizing my channel like
before i would make four minute videos
you barely make any money on those
like that's impossible how can everyone
make so much money oh
oh i'm not monetizing my channel oh okay
cool well maybe that's a part of the
reason
21 billion views that's [ __ ]
nuts dude okay so what i really want to
investigate here
is the top subscribers who's gaining the
most subscribers right now
okay 300 000 in a day jesus christ
knowledge tv teach me
clearly i need to become indian i'm
beginning to see a pattern here
okay well that was analytics with
pewdiepie hope you guys
thought this was interesting i've
literally uploaded every single day
for as long as i can remember taking
minimum breaks
as much as i can possibly today take
it's crazy to me how i still enjoy it i
don't get it either
why am i here it's fun i don't know what
to tell you one thing that i am thinking
about
is like i've never had a proper break
like i never had a long break where i'm
just a normal [ __ ] person
that isn't constantly thinking about
youtube but literally if i took a break
it would kill my channel
the way youtube is shaped at this point
is like you just have to keep making
videos
otherwise there won't be anything to
come back to we've seen this happen to
so many youtubers
that go on a break and then hey guys
what's up oh
everyone is gone oh no they didn't like
leave the algorithm made it
so you know that's always a fun
lingering fact at the back of your mind
being youtuber it's such an easy job you
guys don't understand
it doesn't even matter we're all going
to be replaced by ai in the future
this has been pewdiepie analytics
subscribe god damn it
goodbye what you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price